- C'est un matin où le froid
Dans ce centre commercial
S S Ste-Marie, les boutiques
ne sont pas encore ouvertes,
mais dans les corridors,ntntntn.
- Je ne suis plus capable. Elle
dit : "Je ne suis plus capable".
Ça fait que moi mon baromètre
c'est cette phcococococococococt
"je ne suis plus capable".
- Faute de pouvoir tenir
de
le chef du Parti conservateur
du Québec, Éric Duhaime,
rencontre pour la première fois
la toute nouvelle association
circonscription de Beauce-Nord.
- C'est beau bravo.
Merci d'être là.
- Quelques heures plus tard
fois dans un restaurant de la
circptptptption de Beauce-Sud.
ÉRIC DUHAIME, chef,
Parti conservateur du Québecdedr
en Beauce, on se sent toujoursct
conservateur.
- En quelques mois, u u u u u us
associations dans 105 des 125
circonscriptions du Québec.
En Beauce, chacune d'elle compte
plus- Puis ça travaille parce qn
m'a dit que la majorité
des petites municipalités
avait un représentant.
bien les électeurs et
les organisateurs poeseseses
de la Beauce. Cet ancien député
de l'ADQ constate que l'aiguille
CLAUDE MORIN, maire de Saint-
Georieieieieien député ADQ
- Ça peut être intéressant
de voir ça. Au Parti libéral,'ee
est pas mal à terre, même à laCe
je sens, les noms que j'ai eus,
que j'ai entendus,lslslslslslslt
pour la CAQ avant.
- Et ça se vérifie dans les
rangs conservateurs à en croire
l'av- T'es membre à la CAQ,
c'est ça?
- Je suis membre mais je veux
dire, je suis pas membre.
c'est ça?
- C'est un membre qui
fictif, un peu comme la carte
des Chevalier de Colomb.
essentiellement la bataille
pour lononononon des mesures
sanitaires qui rassemblent
ces militants sous l'enseigne
- Je pense que cette élection-lu
parce que ce qu'on sent très
fortement: l'écoeurite q q q q e
ça s'est développé en anti-CAQ.
- Si le parti peut compter sur
des caquistes déçus,
il en vamimimimimimimimimimimimi
conservateur du Canada.
- Bonjour Monsieur Boutin,
ça va bien?
JASMIN BOUTIN, vice-prés., Asso.
du parti conservateur de
- Même si sur la scène fédérale,
de Maxime Bernier à Richard
règnent sur la Beauce depuis
plus de t t t t t t organisateur
de campagne prend ses distances.
- Je vois aucune alliance puis
là. Ce qui est conservateurraras
valeurs tout à fait.
- Et il met en garde cuiuiuiuius
anti-mesures sanitaires.
- Tout lpapapapapapapapapapapapà
à se réfugier rapidement dans
un parti juste par des
frustrations? Encore une fois,
on va être où? On s'en va où?
On a encore des projets su
la table à réaliser.
Faut pas juste que ce soit
PHILIPPE J. FOURNIER, analyste
pol., créateur de Québec 1
- Monsieur Duhaime et son parti
profitent énormément du contexte
- Les sondages démontrent que
la Beauce n'nonononononononomène
isolé.
- On remarque que c'est dans
la grande région de Québec que
les appuis du PCQ sont les plus
a a a a a a a a regarder plus
particulièrement les couronnes
de Québec et les
circonscriptions sur la Rive-Sud
de Québec, on parle de Léviset .
- Si l'engouement semble
se limiter à quelques
circonscriptions, les électeurs
conservateurs, eux, sont
dispersés à travers tout
le Québec, exception faite
de Montréal.
- L'électeur-type est un peu
plus jeune que la moyenne,
il est majoritairement  mâle,
et il habite soit dans les
banlieues ou dans les régions
du Québec.
Si je suis Monsie
je surveillerais quelques
circonscriptions à Québec parce
que ça pourrait certainement
venir brouiller les cartes.
- ucucucucucucucucuce, Éric
Duhaime, lui, rêve de victoires
avec ses militants.
- Le 3 octobre au soir, quand
ils vont commencer à annoncervis
soyez parmi les premiers.
- À huit mois de l'élection,
bien malin celui qui peut
prédire à quelle position
les conservateurs québécois
franchiront la ligne d'arrivée,
ou même s'ils seront
véritablement de la course.
Ici Valérie Gamache, Radio-
Canada St-Georges en Beauce